um I think in general it's easier to  play against people that I don't like  just because if you're too close or too  friendly with certain other players who  can take the edge off I don't like to  play guys with whom I have a really good  relationship I mean if I like the guy I  cannot feel the time as some sort of  warfare during the game in chess you  know a lot about information you don't  really want to share it I think it for  example is a very very bad idea that  Levon Aronian was was hanging out Magnus  Carlsen prior to this event we hit a  little like a fun session with Magnus  before the tournament you know just  playing some basketball as far as Magnus  goes he's clearly establishes the bass  player so if anything he is more to gain  I think it's much more to his benefit  than it is to lavon's as a rule I don't  think it's appropriate that players who  are both in the top ten work together  but now the one south of the top ten so  now it's okay  you